like no one wants to watch a movie on
how [ __ ] kenja Bane got into Costco
it was [ __ ] boring
the old-fashioned about publicity they
had a board meeting and
reported anybody's life
dude that's kind of cool you're too
clean dude I was fat
[Music]
let's pull this one specifically for Joe
oh JoJo because it's an update on
something that we had talked about that
Joe brought up quite a while ago and a
very recent update has happened origami
dogs no but very great guess I should
Google that later
origami origami U.S fugitive known as
has been apprehended in Venezuela after
weeks on the Run wow dude they caught up
to that guy wow it did let me uh let's
get a little bit of a visual
visual who's fat Leonard again so he is
the guy that wait that's what he looks
like that's what he looks like he looks
a little skinny he's like big boy in the
morning like indo or some [ __ ] I did too
I thought he was like wait isn't he kind
of Indonesian or yeah Southeast Asian
looking that fool looks like a Goomba
yeah so fat Leonard is the guy who um
started working up the ranks in this uh
Shipping Company
that would provide catering and things
for major cruise ships and stuff and
then he got an account with the U.S Navy
and when he was working for the U.S Navy
he also became the go-to hookup for
drugs prostitutes and anything the
soldiers wanted and then he worked up
his ranks to high military officials and
then he basically blackmailed them and
said dude I got all these photos of you
[ __ ] underage girls or whatever
whatever or he would bribe them and then
like just be like hey dude I know you
like that Crown Royal man I'll hook you
up some Crown Royal make sure all of the
ships come through my port because then
he wanted all the business so the Navy
didn't need to like they're like yo this
should be going to Yokohama why the [ __ ]
is it stopping in like Indonesia or
whatever it was right and then so
because he went up the chains to like
such high levels of U.S Navy
and he had them all in his pocket that
he was making so much [ __ ] money from
the U.S taxpayers that all this [ __ ]
came crumbling down when one of the uh
Navy officials basically was caught
cheating by his wife and you know women
make the best detectives right because
when they suspect cheating dude they're
MacGyver like full on so she went
through his emails all that [ __ ] and
then she just basically ratted him out
to the Navy and be like this
motherfucker's been [ __ ] hookers
provided by your own you know [ __ ]
company and all this stuff and then so
they went and did this whole
investigation and they found out that
fat Leonard had the whole U.S Navy in
his [ __ ] pocket and they're like that
is a security breach but imagine all the
U.S Navy soldiers just on the ship like
going in circles and just be like oh
what are we doing yeah I don't know
actually a comment on this article was
somebody vomited and said my son was on
one of the affected ships lhd2 and says
that it was common knowledge that the
ship would waste multiple days going to
Fat Leonard's ports to reprovision
[ __ ] damn Yep they're like oh wait we
got a YouTubers per day must be insane
so a military contractor known as fat
Leonard uh pleaded after pleading guilty
in a major Navy corruption Scandal was
apprehended in Venezuela in order to do
this he cut off his ankle bracelet and
fled by the way so Leonard Glenn Francis
who was on house arrest in San Diego and
weeks away from sentencing removed his
GPS tracker on September I love how he
was just on house arrest chilling in San
Diego dude no wonder I would have tried
to escape too Francis uh Francis had
pleaded guilty in 2015 to bribing Navy
officials in a 35 million dollar Scandal
oh Francis was captured by Venezuelan
authorities who had been made aware that
he was on the Run by Interpol as he was
trying to board a plane Bound for
another country
uh director uh General Interpol
Venezuela said a statement that Francis
had entered the country from Mexico with
a stopover in Cuba his final destination
was Russia
he was apprehended at Simone Bolivar
International Airport and will remain in
Venezuela custody while U.S Marshals and
other Federal authorities work out
details of his extradition to the U.S
for that backstory a little bit extra
detail he was arrested in 2013 and
pleaded guilty to offering half a
million dollars in bribes to Navy
officers who in exchange shared
classified information with him and
redirected military vessels to Port that
would be beneficial for his
singapore-based ship Servicing Company
the 35 million dollars comes from the
fact that Francis and his firm
overcharged the U.S military more than
35 million dollars for constantly
stopping into his ports and everything
like that damn and he's been under house
arrests since 2018. that's how he made a
lot of money too is like he would let's
say you know do all the catering for the
military and charge a lot for like
chicken or something and they would let
him because they're getting greased on
the side yeah the the officials would
let him but also you know they were was
that just the up charge for everything
else
yeah like they you know he was just
making money in every different way you
know why is corruption so cool it's
pretty cool you know what I mean because
if
I landed this thing where like they
carry my my new like gummy snacks you
know in Costco you're like oh that's a
good job dude you know but then when
you're like hey dude so like I paid this
[ __ ] politician and he's gonna put my
gummy snacks in every single 7-Eleven at
Costco
yeah cause I got all these photos of
this guy [ __ ] [ __ ] all these
chicks
um he's in Costco you're like man that
was a sweet business
why is it so cool pretty smart because
you don't want to watch a movie on the
other one like no one wants to watch a
movie on how [ __ ] kenja Bing got into
Costco it was [ __ ] boring
the old-fashioned the bad publicity they
had a board meeting and Anthony Lee's
never extorted anybody's life
dude that's kind of cool you're too
clean dude I was fat but what does that
have to do with Costco I don't know this
guy's name is fat Leonard uh did they
charge any of the Navy officers they
should they should dude not a lot of
course not I don't know there was some
scapegoats lower ranking but that's one
of the things when I watched that
documentary it was like yeah it's it's
because the letter was just providing a
service right yeah they're the ones
asking for that exactly like it's all
started because the Navy guys were
asking them hey you know where I could
get some ecstasy yeah or like hey we're
just trying to do this like super nice
dinner
um can you find us some prostitutes some
expensive steaks or whatever so it all
started from that which ended up with
prostitution and all that and then
Leonard was like oh these guys are
[ __ ] scumbags let me just take a
picture or or record them partying and
cheating on their wives and all that and
then he was just providing a service
does he I don't know so for me I'm
conflicted right it's like
if
the corrupt people that want these
Services didn't exist in the first place
Leonard would have no power but it's our
own U.S Navy service people that are
asking for the service yeah if it wasn't
fat Leonard they may have been somebody
else exactly are you saying that our
high-ranking officials should be the
ones that are criminalized in this I
mean sucks yeah it's got to be high
ranked both right it has to be it's got
to be dude because then they're the ones
you can make the call yeah it has to be
the high ranking because they could
always be like no nobody gets the [ __ ]
and in the high ranking ones making it
so that our tax dollars are being
[ __ ] overspent on all this [ __ ]
because of their own selfish reasons
yeah yeah very true probably the same
[ __ ] visiting Epstein's Island
too exactly I wonder how they're
escaping prosecution in this case what
are they saying are they like he's the
Fall Guy fat letters I just get a Fall
Guy and they just saying he took
advantage of us yeah we didn't know
yeah a couple foreign
and on top of that like think about the
security threat if we lose some like
like super Admiral General level people
oh yeah and it's like dude these guys
are like top brains you [ __ ] those guys
they're gonna get they're gonna get you
back you're cutting off the head of the
snake option dude I think I could be
good at corruption you think you could
be good I think you're way too honorable
no yeah you'll be sad you would get
crushed in the first day dude you're not
very sexually aroused by power so I
don't think you don't know that you
don't know that about me I think we all
are we just haven't got a taste of it
yet once we get that sweet taste you you
would be a good uh corruption cosplayer
oh
I was a pretty honorable criminal I
wouldn't even cheat on my test I would
cheat on my test so that that's how I
know I would be I don't like corruption
I just want a shot just give me a shot
out there okay I do like justice give me
a shot uh the first activities of the
conspiracy were confirmed to have
existed in 2006 when Francis recruited
numerous Navy personnel to engage in
corruption including directing contracts
toward his firm disfavoring competitors
and inhibiting legitimate fiscal and
operational oversight the initial
co-conspirators labeled themselves quote
the cool kids and quote the wolf pack
U.S federal spelling they've filed
criminal charges against 33 individuals
lock them up yeah 33 individuals in
connection with the fat Leonard Scandal
of those 22 pleaded guilty Francis
himself four of his top aides and 17
Navy officials specifically at least 10
commissioned officers two Petty officers
one former NCIS the special agent and
two civilian Navy Contracting officials
nine others are awaiting trial in U.S
District Court in San Diego I just want
to say that
why do they call them fat Leonard
because he's fat yeah but why can't they
just be Leonard
yeah but nobody's like fat president
Trump is just president Trump damn it
because president is already like
there's only two words
president Trump there's a bunch of
Leonards out there so you need to know
which one's which lender the fat one the
fat one yeah
I think that was the code too that could
even be the code
um investigators that's his nickname fat
Leonard or something like that they're
very not body positive and no so that's
your issue with it they're like comes
from slack man you're like he's not even
that fat it might be one of the secret
he never even called himself that and he
never even knew people called he's like
wait wait you guys are call me fat man
what's the case gets out he's like are
you [ __ ] serious I worked really hard
on my way man my Navy homies were
calling me fat letters 30 pounds you
know do you think that's why there's
always a fat Tony and a an Italian group
because everyone's named Tony so they're
like which Tony Fat Tony yeah you're not
gonna say it you're not gonna say skinny
Tony you're just gonna say small Tony or
Tony Little Tony yeah little fat Tony
Little Tony Kenny Tony you call him Tony
bones Tony dude
[Music]